question for mark i was just watching
the
uh chrissy chaos episode that you were
on about five or six months ago and you
were talking about
uh your seinfeld story
um how you were opening up for him and
then covet hit and
i was just curious what the status of
y'all's current relationship is have you
heard from him in the last five or six
months are you going to be working with
him again
in the future
uh just curious about that i'm also a
big seinfeld fan
gang gang theo i love you uh y'all keep
doing your thing man
gang baby love you too brother thank you
people love you
people love you ah not my dad
but
yeah either way
uh the seinfeld thing is crazy because
uh
i was a huge fan i watched it with my
parents growing up and then now to have
his phone number is his bananas yeah
but uh it's almost like the hot girl i
open for him one weekend we did four
shows we went out after i had wine had
pizza tiramisu best night of my life
and
cove had hit so then everything got
weird and then i kept trying to text him
it's like a girl you [__] once that
you're in love with but yeah the
relationship's just kind of distancing
but you try to keep it going with a text
but
it's inevitable it's not gonna last but
uh
i'll text him every now and then and
he'll get back to me so i'll take it
yeah
i talked about norm dying and he was he
had some cool [__] to say that's cool
yeah so
i hate to say it but sometimes an event
happens like that you're like oh this is
a good opportunity to text the big jew
yeah you got to go bj on that dude
yeah yeah exactly yeah it's interesting
how like if you get a somebody's number
that's a celebrity or that's popular to
you yeah then like how nervous you feel
like and then you also start to
recognize how like their lives are so
busy that they just
it's not that they don't care anything
about you the friendship just picks back
up kind of when you see each other again
there's just not as much down time to
communicate like yeah completely there's
just not as much free time as when you
were just
chilling and you [__] just didn't
have anything to do yeah yeah and he's a
little older so he's not part of that
text generally we'll just text back and
forth and he's
i think he takes a while to get back to
you you know he's a thinker also
that's true
so i'm just happy because you know how
much power i have just having his i
could give that out i could call him
drunk i mean i could do so many bad
things so i'm really trying to be a good
good little boy with his number number
shepard yes exactly yeah and uh
sometimes you like have all the numbers
and then you get drunk and lose one runs
down the hill oh there's a six yeah yeah
i hope no one knows anything yeah right
i texted him once drunk and i ha i never
did it again because he his reaction was
kind of like i could tell it was weird
he was weirded out
but he's cool he's so normal he's like
us you know you talk to him you're like
oh you're just a dude yeah and we put
him up on this uh weird pedestal but
he's just like us yeah he's just busier
and richer
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one